الانقلابات كثيره اسبابها بعضها تكون
داخليه ترتبط اساسا بنظام الحكم ربما يكون
نظام الحكم استبدادي لا يعطي فرصه لحريه
التعبير يكون هناك انقساط انقسام داخل
المؤسسه العسكريه هناك حاله من التذمر لدى
هذه المؤسسه من ممارسات هذا النظام ربما
يكون النظام يفضل بعض الوحدات على بعضها
كالحرس رئاسي مثلا مقارنه بباقي الوحدات
العسكريه فيؤدي ذلك الى حمقها وانتهاز
الفرصه المناسبه هذه الفرصه تتمثل في وجود
حاله من التذمر الشعبي بسبب سوء الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه وسوء الاوضاع الاجتماعيه وعدم
وجود حريه تعبير قوانين مقيده للحريات
عمليات اعتقالات مستمره وياتي هؤلاء
العسكر ليضعوا اجندتهم التي ربما تكون
ديمقراطيه تسمح بتداول السلطه بعد فتره
انتقاليه كما حدث في نيجيريا في عهد عبد
السلام ابو بكر مثلا على سبيل المثال او
ربما تؤدي الى ديكتاتوريه اخرى مدنيه
بخلفيه عسكريه
البعد الخارجي الخارجي مهم ايضا نقصد به
البعد الاقليمي والبعد الدولي ربما تحدث
هناك اتفاقات سريه غير معلنه نكتشفها بعد
ذلك عندما ياتي قاده الانقلاب ولا نجد
معارضه قويه لهم او ربما اكتفاء بعض الدول
بالتمديد فقط
والحديث عن الرغبه في التحول الديمقراطي
حتى وان جاءت الانتخابات الديمقراطيه
بهؤلاء القلابيين في زي عسكري فوجدنا مثلا
على سبيل المثال تعامل فرنسا مع انقلاب
الجابون يختلف كثيرا لان الرئيس بونجو على
سبيل المثال علي بونجو المطاح به كان على
خلاف مع فرنسا في الفتره الاخيره فربما
كان موقف فرنسا داعم لهؤلاء الانقلابيين
حتى وان لم تعلن ذلك صراحه كانت من يريد
من النظم الخروج عن العباءه الفرنسيه او
تحديدا الفرانك الفرنسي المعروف في
افريقيا بسيبا في دول غرب افريقيا من كان
يريد ان يخرج من هذه المظله الفرنسيه او
يخرج عن عباءه الاقتصاد الفرنسي او
التبعيه الفرنسيه كان مصيره اما الاغتيال
او الانقلاب عليه حتى تضمن فرنسا وتضمن
هذه الدول وجود نظم تابعه وخاضعه لها
الصراعات الدوليه دائما ما تكون لها
انعكاسات على النظم الافريقيه لان هذه
النظم تستمد قوتها ليس من شعوبها في
الاغلب العام ولكن من التاييد الخارجي لها
فعندما يكون الطرف الداعم لنظام مشغول في
صراع دولي او في صراع مع قوه اخرى
يكون هذا النظام ضعيفا او يعني يعني تنكشف
عنه ورقه التوت التي كان يدعمها او يعطي
خصومه الفرصه لكي يتامروا او يشجعوا
الانقلابات عليه وحدث هذا في كثير من
الدول ونذكر على سبيل المثال
التنافس الدولي ما بين الولايات المتحده
روسيا وفرنسا واستغلال روسيا وجود حاله من
عدم الاستقرار السياسي في ليبيا لدعم
ميليشيا خليفه حفتر في الشرق بهدف السيطره
على البلاد والتوجه الى طرابلس حيث
الحكومه المعترف بها من اجل انقلاب عليها
وتنصيب خليفه حفتر من اجل ان يكون لروسيا
موطئ قدم في هذه البلد في ليبيا التي كانت
دائما يعني مكانا للنفوذ الغربي والفرنسي
والامريكي لكن وجدنا ان هذا الانقلاب فشل
بسبب استعانه هذه تذكر ايضا استعانت
الحكومه في طرابلس بتركيا ودخول القوات
التركيه على الخط لمنع هذا الانقلاب وبقاء
الوضع في ليبيا كما هو عليه اذا التنافس
الدولي يؤدي اما الى تاجيل الصراعات يؤدي
الى دعم الانقلابات يؤدي الى مزيد مزيد من
عدم الاستقرار في القاره الافريقيه
المنطقه المرشحه لان تكون يعني مكان او
فرصه لحدوث انقلبت غرب افريقيا ووسط
افريقيا لماذا التداخل بين هذه المنطقتين
تحديدا والوجود عوامل مشابهه تهيئ لحدوث
انقلابات لاسيما وجود نظم
مستبده ديكتاتوريه
باقيه في الحكم منذ حوالي ثلاثه عقود او
اربع عقود بعض النظم وبالتالي هناك تحيل
وتربص بهذه النظم مع اول فرصه ستاتي
للمؤسسه العسكريه لكي تنقلب عليها ربما
بعض الدول تكون مرشحه ليس ليس على سبيل
الجزم مثلا مثل غينيا الاستوائيه مثل
الكونغو برزفيل او غيرها
الاستقرار السياسي له عده شروط او معايير
حتى يتحقق منها المعيار الاقتصادي
والمعيار السياسي المعيار الاقتصادي يتمثل
في تحقيق حاله من الوضع المعيشي الجيد
للشعوب الافريقيه فاذا تحقق هذا الشرط لن
تتعرض هذه الشعوب للنظم وبالتالي هناك بعض
النظم نجحت في هذا الامر في ان تحقق حاله
من الاستقرار
في البلاد رغم انها نظم مستبده والمثال
على ذلك حاله رواندا معدل نمو اقتصادي
يبلغ حوالي تسعه في المئه حاله من
الشفافيه في المجال الاقتصادي ومحاربه
الفساد
ومقابل ذلك حاله من الاستبداد السياسي
وقمع المعارضه ووجود رئيس لرئيس اللي هو
بول كادمي يحكم منذ حوالي ثلاثه عقود ولكن
وجدنا ان رواندا تشهد حاله من الاستقرار
اذا الشعوب الافريقيه مطالبها بسيطه وهو
تحقيق حاله معيشيه جيده في الوضع
الاقتصادي الامر الثاني هو الجانب
الديمقراطي وهو ان يكون هناك متنفسا
للشعوب ديمقراطيه شبه مقيده كما يطلق
عليها البعض او نظريه القدر الكاتم الذي
يسمح بهامش من الحريه لبعض القوى السياسيه
حتى يتم التنفيس عن حاله الغضب لدى هذه
الشعوب لكن النظم التي تغلق المجال كاملا
ثم لا تحسن الاوضاع الاقتصاديه ستشهد
مزيدا من عدم الاستقرار